Noise in Quantum systems refers to the interaction
of the system with the rest of the world.
Such interactions are crucial for any sort
of computation and in effect enables classical
computing.
Noise is related to three fundamental topics.
The 1st topic is time dependent processes
and thus also to the notion of time in general.
A time dependent processes require interaction
with the environment and therefore it requires
some amount of noise.
The second notion is the notion of locality.
Locality in quantum systems refers to the
effect quantum processes usually involve between
a small number of particles.
And it is very important to understand locality.
According to my analysis quantum computational
supremacy is an artifact of incomplete modeling
of local quantum systems that need to bring
noise and even a substantial amount of noise
in there definition.
And the third is the connection to computation.
It is the interaction of the environment and
noise that enables robust classical information
and robust classical computation.
And it turns out that when the amount of interaction
with the environment is small the quantum
processes are very limited computationally
and very primitive computationally and such
primitive computation power does not enable
computational supremacy and it does not enable
building quantum error correcting codes that
are necessary for quantum computing.